[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ça
vous regarde
à la une ce soir fait partie pour quatre
semaines au moins de confinement
suffisant ou pas pour enrayer l'épidémie
s'est en tout cas l'occasion pour nous
de nous interroger ce soir sur les bon
élève ducobu
quels sont les pays à imiter comment la
chine ou encore taïwan ont réussi à
écraser le virus 1re confinement nous
prévient-il forcément d'une troisième
vague question au coeur de notre grand
débat ce soir notre grand témoin lui est
un mâle blanc hétérosexuel de plus de 60
ans et il n'a pas du tout l'intention de
s'en excuser il fustige dans son dernier
livre la france et des colonials la
pensée anti raciste l'idéologie du néo
féminisme tout cela ferait de l'homme
blanc un coupable
presque parfait c'est le titre le
philosophe pascal bruckner est avec nous
ce soir sans oublier bien sûr le bloc
notes du vendredi françois durpaire pour
la campagne américaine nous à 5 jours
maintenant de l'élection une nouvelle
chronique internationale avec isabelle
lasserre et la période camille camille
saféris avec un député ce sera à la fin
de cette émission voilà pour le
programme hashtag cbr pour réagir tout
de suite le grand débat
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
bonsoir pascal bruckner bonsoir merci
d'être là c'est un plaisir de vous
accueillir vous êtes très très remontés
dans ce dernier opus votre dernier livre
contre cette idéologie venu de la gauche
américaine qui découpent la société en
identité blessé et qui imposeraient une
forme de police de la pensée ça
s'appelle un coupable presque parfait
chez grasset sous titre la construction
du bouc émissaire blanc va en parler
longuement dans la deuxième partie de
cette émission mais on va s'intéresser
d'abord à la pandémie alors dur
confinement français pourquoi certains
pays s'en sortent mieux que nos bons
soirs car et 2100 bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes économiste
chercheuse au cnrs et spécialiste des
systèmes de santé vous publiez health
care reform in china en français c'est
la réforme de la santé chinoise c'est
aux éditions pas grave
pivot et c'est dans toutes les bonnes
librairies numériques je ne les citerai
pas vous les connaissez à bonsoir
yonatan freund
merci d'être là cet urgentiste à
l'hôpital de la pitié salpêtrière
vous nous direz pourquoi on fait un peu
moins bien ou mieux que d'autres en tout
cas ce qui se passe dans votre hôpital à
john tu es députés en marche des
français qui vivent en asie va nous
rejoindre dans un instant et bonsoir
stéphane bontemps murs y sommes des fans
des causses qui qui ouvre le bal de ce
premier débat avec son billet d'actu si
j'ai bien compris tout de suite
stéphane analyse comparative des bons et
des mauvais élève ducobu de benchmarking
comme on dit
en anglais alors si j'ai bien compris et
myriam voilà il ya maintenant presque un
an que la pandémie de co lead a commencé
et donc on a le recul nécessaire pour
comparer les méthodes appliquées selon
les pays et donc savoir quelle est la
méthode la plus efficace pour lutter
contre des russes donc c'est déjà une
bonne nouvelle on peut savoir alors
qu'elle est la meilleure jamais la
meilleure méthode alors hélas hélas
myriam est ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle j'en suis pas sûr parce que il
s'avère que apparemment là mais pub la
plus efficace c'est la méthode dite
autoritaire faut frapper vite et fort et
sur une large échelle et donc l'exemple
pour ça le champion l'a vu contre le
blitz et le vietnam
voyez les échos au mois d'octobre cette
année sur le fait qu' il ya eu très peu
de mots regrettable et qu'en plus la
croissance économique se poursuit
dans ce pays alors les dingues pour
quelques chips et 96 millions
d'habitants en fin octobre il a vu on
l'affronté 35 morts donc un tout décès
de 0,04 sur 100000 alors qu'en france on
est plutôt à 50 pour cent mille alors
quelle est cette méthode vietnamienne
bon alors déjà le truc c'est que le
vietnam a réagi rapidement peut-être
parce qu'ils avaient eu l'expérience du
sras en 2003 donc quand on parle et ils
ont créé un conseil scientifique par
exemple le 30 janvier nous on a attendu
le 11 mars
ils ont fermé les frontières 1er février
nous entendu fermé schengen le 17 mars
et puis alors surtout ils ont frappé
fort d'où le côté méthodes autoritaires
c'est à dire que toute personne qui est
contaminée au vietnam et les enfermer
non pas chez elle mais dans un hôpital
avec interdiction de sortir tant qu'on
n'est pas négatif
tous les cas comptable de cette personne
sont eux aussi isolé non pas chez eux
mais dans des locaux parfois même des
camps militaires dont peuvent être
parfois aux quatre par par chambre on
mange à la cantine comme tout le monde
et puis bien sûr il ya le côté
répression puisque le port du masque en
public est obligatoire et que ça ne
rigole pas j'ai lu dans la presse que un
vietnamien qui avait contesté un peu
trop fort le port du masque avait été
condamné à neuf mois de prison
donc ça veut dire que les régimes
autoritaires sont mieux armés que nous
on peut dire ça alors c'est ce qu'on
pourrait se dire notamment quand on voit
comment la chine apparemment a réussi à
stopper le virus a one la vie a repris
mais il se trouve qu'en fait des
démocraties ont n'ont pas hésité elle
non plus à mettre en oeuvre des mesures
qu'on peut quand même jugé assez
autoritaire c'est par exemple le cas de
l'australie qui vous savez a imposé dans
certaines régions un couvre-feu un
pardon un confinement de trois mois il
ya des drones qui circulent pour
surveiller la population peut y avoir
des visites de la police chez vous pour
vérifier que vous êtes bien en
quarantaine sont même pas besoin de deux
mandats
et puis alors est ce que vous avez pu
lire depuis tout à l'heure et que je
gardais pour la fin le meilleur c'est
qu'il ya aussi la une politique de
répression a été forte
voyez on avait parlé de cette femme qui
était enceinte qu'elle est contestée le
confinement son facebook et qui était
arrêté par la police
comment réagissent les populations alors
est ce qu'elle se rebelle ben non pas
forcément les populations se rappelle
pas forcément enfin tout cas par exemple
la nouvelle-zélande a aussi eu mis en
place des politiques assez sévère sur le
confinement le contrôle tout ça et puis
comme vous êtes efficaces ces mesures
eh ben on n'en veut pas au pouvoir en
place regardez il ya des élections début
octobre et la première ministre a été
réélu d'ailleurs triomphale c'est la
première fois que imparti à la majorité
complète au parlement
en nouvelle zélande la demande
d'autorité est ce que ça veut dire que
finalement c'est la bonne méthode il
fallait roku fini tout est là après tout
ce que je viens de vous dire oui je peux
pas là difficilement dire le contraire
si on veut un dernier exemple c'est le
cas d'israël qui a re confiné donc comme
nous mais depuis la mi septembre et
parisien publié donc les fameuses
courbes et voyez que après être monté
très haut la courbe de contamination a
vraiment baissé en israël alors que nous
on était encore temps voilà en train de
monter donc on peut espérer le même
effet en france la question qu'on peut
se poser malgré tout c'est ce que le
confinement sera terminé pour les fêtes
de fin d'année merci stéphane on va
revenir sur les différentes situations
continent par continent juste pour
répondre à stéphane vous n'êtes pas de
vin vous êtes médecin
will et on pourra passer nos vacances en
famille à noël à votre avis ça j'en sais
rien mais en tout cas je pour répondre à
la stéphane je suis pas du tout d'accord
avec ce qu'il dit un jour d'hui on peut
pas du tout dire qui on est et où on pas
été les bons élèves c'est pas possible
qu est ce qu est trop salée de ce qui va
se passer dans un an trois ans et puis
c'est pas du tout j'ai pas l'impression
que c'est par rapport à une espèce
d'autorité d'un gouvernement ou d'une
démocratie ou pas les pays qui ont été
cités ces des pays qui maîtrisent leurs
frontières leurs frontières c'est de la
flotte ou c'est la frontière avec la
corée du nord où la frontière avec la
scion des îles well hors des frontières
qu'on peut maîtriser si après le grand
confinement quand il y avait une
circulation à trèbes à bruz du virus on
avait fermé complètement les frontières
et qu'on avait pu analyser toutes les
personnes qui entraient évidemment qu'on
aura été les bons élèves mais je pense
que c'est beaucoup trop tôt pour dire
qu'ils étaient bons élèves ou qui n'a
pas été il n'a pas cité la salle jardin
mêlant quand même 21 lors c'était
décembre dernier on peut regarder le
virus à maurane mais on peut regarder se
passer mais je vais vous donner un
exemple simple et je dis pas que c'est
ce qui va se passer mais imaginons que
la suède ou la france ont été
insuffisamment exposés on en a pris
plein la figure pendant un an ou deux
après la vie reprend et que en chine
il reste pendant des années et des
années dans l'inquiétude que le virus
ressortent là bas alors que nous on aura
passé peut-être cette histoire bon on va
continuer à en parler bonsoir agent s
vous permet de vous accueillir vous êtes
député en marche des français qui vivent
en asie circonscription quel pays pour
rappeler rapidement toute l'asie tous
les hits du sud-est l'océanie la russie
l'iran vous allez nous dire comment les
français qui sont là-bas vive vive les
choses mais pour rebondir
karine mills
on va partir de la chine quand même la
chine c'est un milliard un milliard et
demi d'habitants
on a vu ces images amour and de jeunes
chinois qui font la fête dans des méga
boîte de nuit
comment comment on peut expliquer ça
qu'est ce qu'est ce qui a fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression que
c'est maîtrisé c'est le cas ou pas déjà
marié de choses il ya le contrôle un
contrôle excessivement série c'est à
dire que dès qu'il y a le moindre la
moindre suspicion de cas on ferme la
zone et on met les gens en quarantaine
sur cette zone
et puis vous teste les gens sont tracées
ils sont vérifiées le masque est encore
obligatoire il ya l'intérêt fin
l'extérieur que c'est maîtriser la
situation sur place on peut croire les
chiffres et nos 10 47 nouveaux 4
coronavirus en y fut ces dernières 24
heures il faut prendre du recul par
rapport aux chiffres je pense qu'il ne
faut pas et que enfin se coller aux
chiffres et avoir une comparaison
stricto sensu des chiffres pays après
pays
il faut garder en tête que même en
france il n'est pas si évident enfin que
dire c'est relativement complexe pour
santé publique france d'avoir des
chiffres qui sont comparables
donc on a des chiffres comparables mais
ça demande un exercice assez complexe
donc vous imaginez bien au niveau de la
planète avec des systèmes d'information
qui sont extrêmement disparate avec d
une cyber technologie qui est également
très très très différente eh bien il est
évident qu'on ne peut pas comparer les
chiffres de la même manière un agent est
on se dit que la chine a quand même un
certain savoir-faire pour le meilleur
comme pour le pire parce que c'est quand
même très contrôlé sa population d'une
façon générale il ya des pays
limitrophes
on a parlé du vietnam dans la chronique
de stéphane on pourrait parler de taiwan
c'est vrai que c'est une île mais alors
là c'est vrai qu'on est on est surpris
ils ont quasiment aucun cas depuis le
début taiwan vient de fêter les 200
jours 100 nouveaux cas donc c'est assez
remarquable effectivement ils ont flairé
mais attends ça s'arrête unis alors
c'est une île ce qui inquiète ensuite
ils ont mis en place des systèmes
effectivement de contrôle alors
attention il n'y a pas de confinement
comme chez nous n'y a pas eu de
confinement qui a pas eu d'obligation
non plus de 2 port du masque ça a été
recommandée et puis j'ai une culture aux
siens qui fait qu'on ce qu'on se prête
volontiers aux consignes qui sont
données
aussi un sens du collectif
particulièrement développée à taiwan
taiwan était aussi si on prend l'exemple
de taiwan pour cette région à qui est
particulière vous corrigerez si je me
trompe mais qui avait quand même
anticipé énormément parce qu'ils sont
toujours le souci d'être très
indépendants ils se savent assez isolés
ils se savent pas forcément aidé et
soutenu faisait venir qu'ils ont tous
fermé mais je pensais qu'il est va
taïwan
ils sont pas et ne peuvent pas repartir
ah non non non non la pauvre on les
empêche même de petites et s'ils veulent
revenir en france en janvier il ya eu
différentes approches je sais plus
précisément aujourd'hui où ils en sont
pour taiwan en tout cas il ya un certain
nombre de pays on n'a pas pu revenir
alors pour aller en dehors de l'asie y
compris l'australienne nouvelle zélande
les français là bas ne peuvent pas
rentrer et donc s'ils ont un parent
proche qui est en difficulté ne peuvent
pas venir le voir ou alors on leur
impose des quarantaines retour parfois
leur ferait donc il ya des conditions
logistiques financières qui font qu'on
ne revient pas forcément facilement mais
en même temps tout le monde joue le jeu
en disant ils voient bien ce qui se
passe chez nous chez nous à taïwan en
corée au japon
finalement la situation est maîtrisée je
peux vivre normalement
j'ai mon boulot pas un tous les secteurs
car ces pays là faut pas oublier que les
secteurs également du tourisme de
l'hôtellerie de la restauration sont
lourdement impacter tous qui est
touristique j'avais des gens du laos au
téléphone ya pas longtemps s'est
fortement impacté ya plus de contacts ya
plus de communication donc ils doivent
se recentrer sur d'autres industries
d'autres secteurs pour réussir à trouver
une croissance et les relais de
croissance car on voit que finalement
c'est pas forcément les pays
totalitaires ou autoritaires qui s'en
sortent le mieux il ya des démocraties
qui arrive mais il ya quand même des
cultures qui permettent aussi une
certaine forme de l'obéissance aux
règles c'est ça qu'on paye aujourd'hui à
votre avis nous en europe
oui en france écouté hier soir 23 heures
j'ai entendu des hurlements en bas de
chez moi j'habite près de république
s'il y avait une manifestation contre le
contre le confinement tout le monde
était ce confinement macron démission
tout ce qu'on entend depuis quelques
temps et entre la rébellion et le
conformiste ya peut-être une attitude un
peu plus sage parce que là c'est
vraiment le conformiste de la rébellion
systématique et c'est vrai qu'en asie
j'y vais depuis de nombreuses années il
ya une culture confucéenne qui fait que
le collectif a autorité sur le caprice
individuelle est bon on voit bien que
lorient 2 me
la scène du monde aujourd'hui et que
c'est ça qui nous manque aujourd'hui
pour éviter la saturation des hôpitaux
c'est une forme de discipline
non je pense pas à des conditions encore
une fois on accuse les gens les
culpabiliser on les responsabilise le
rebond depuis tout à l'heure on cite pas
le cas de la suède la suède s'est pas là
on allait en parler mais allez-y si vous
voulez par un état qui est extrêmement
autoritaire j'ai l'impression alors
expliquez nous pour ceux qui n'ont pas
suivi l paris a fait la suède la suède a
fait un pari et qu'on peut critiquer ou
pas mais encore une fois c'est bien plus
tard qu'on pourra savoir si c'est payant
c'est celui de ne pas confiné et de
l'immunité collective ou en tout cas
d'une immunité suffisante d'une
propagation du virus qui fait que la
plupart des gens enfin beaucoup de
personnes vont être infectées
puis après vont être des bloqueurs pour
la propagation du virus
il a eu beaucoup de décès au début la
beaucoup de décès mais il ya eu un
nombre de décès qui est à un ordre de
grandeur qui équivalent à tous les
autres pays touchés
c'est un peu moins que la belgique un
peu plus que la france un peu plus tôt
comme l'espagne l'italie et ces ados
tout qu'est-ce que vous en compris j'en
conclus pas grand chose sauf que l'on
peut pas aujourd'hui dire que tel pays
est un bon élève parce que ça ne repart
pas et d'épée pas parler de la suède par
exemple que ça veut dire que ni lui ni
tête groupe ne rien faire ça reste une
option gens sérieux l'ontarien venant
derrière peuvent avoir une deuxième
vague mais je pense que c'est beaucoup
trop tôt pour dire autoritaire bien pas
autoritaire mal et enfin pour la
discipline et les mesures l'espagne et
l'italie et l'espagne en particulier
avait des mesures beaucoup plus
contraignante que nous ils ont des
conflits nés beaucoup plus lentement
très vite des cas eu des retours de cas
à barcelone puis à madrid ils ont
confiné par quartier ils sont allés
beaucoup plus vite que nous et ils ont
repris la deuxième vague avant noël
entre la question est simple qu'est ce
qui fait que nous en france on en est au
même point qu'au début de la première
vague est ce que qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce
qu'il explique vous avez des
épidémiologistes qui vous disent que
c'est le froid
d'autres qui vous disent qu'on a des
consignes et trop brutalement alors que
vous nous dites que c'est pas le cas
puisqu'on suez dont en espagne c'est
pire qu'au chez nous et ils ont fait ça
progressivement qu'est ce qui te fait
qu'on en est là au même point que au
départ mais à peu de choses près encore
une fois un ordre de grandeur près et à
deux mois près c'est pareil dans tous
les pays européens à peu de choses près
l'espagne l'italie la belgique les états
unis le mexique une traite inexpliquée
blague c'est je pense qu'on peut pas
faire vraiment autrement c'est à dire
que vous avez globalement deux
possibilités soit vous étouffer
complètement le truc et vous laissez
plus rien rentré vous avez tous fait le
feu vous laissez plus une seule
étincelle rang
très soit vous essayez d'avoir une
combustion un peu maîtrisée mais vous
citez donc gestion maîtrisée c'est leur
confinement combustion des crises et
parce qu'on se dit gestion maîtrisée ça
repart après si c'est pas après
extension si on est un tout puis corps
lâche ça repart mais si on laisse le
matériau se se brûler un petit moment et
c'est parce qu'il restera mais carey
ministre oui j'ai enfin il faut bien
voir que sur le territoire chinois n'y a
pas que maurane quand ils ont été
confinés c'est l'ensemble du territoire
chinois qui étaient confinés qui avaient
des provinces ou avant même qu'ils aient
réellement des cas ils ont confiné comme
pékin province de pékin pour des raisons
évidentes c'est là où se trouvent les
nouvelles plusieurs confinement
disparates à différents moments il ya eu
la grande période de confinement et puis
même aujourd'hui vous avez déconfinement
dès qu'il ya le moindre eau rien de spix
suffisant moindre kloster on black bloc
et on confine à nouveau mais les gens
l'acceptent parce que de toute façon ils
n'ont pas le choix et il faut enfin je
pense qu'il faut malgré tout relativiser
cette idée la culture asiatique le
confucianisme
il ya quand même eu l'épisode du sras ce
qui les a excessivement marqué en 2003
qui a été très traumatisants
ils ont déjà leur mairie d'anticiper sur
tous les deux prendre des mesures très
très tôt mais surtout ils ont déjà vécu
ce que nous vivons depuis nous avions
déjà vécu ça il y a quinze ans nous
réagirions autrement aujourd'hui que tel
qu'à taiwan donc si vous voulez que nous
n'avons pas forcément une à savoir faire
ou alors une acceptation si vous voulez
une résilience par rapport aux choses
quoi qu'ils ont acquis qu est que et
parce que parce que c'est dans une
histoire et que nous allons acquérir
également donc je pense qu'il faut
malgré tout garder ça en tête et puis le
deuxième point c'est je suis restée moi
d'accord on sait pas ce qui va se passer
en chine
une fois que tout soit il continue à
contraindre fortement la population soit
ce n'est pas le cas et dans trois ans il
est possible que parce que les gens
n'ont pas d'immunité
il ya des nouveaux cas en chine est
pendante sur la chine
on ya de la transparence sur ce qui s'y
passe aujourd'hui sur les bilans qu'il
donne où on peut pas leur faire
confiance
je vais pas prendre de position précise
la tuer à tout cas il ya un certain
nombre de chiffres qui sont je suis tout
à fait d'accord je vous avais dit tout à
l'heure c'est à dire qu'il faut prendre
y compris chez nous avec prudence tous
les chiffres faut les croire et les
chiffres sont bons ensuite c'est
toujours des nuances disons que
globalement les chiffres il faut les
prendre tels qu'ils sont ils sont là on
peut les croire je voudrais aussi
insisté sur le fait qu' il ya une
question de transmission de lutte contre
la chaîne de transmission le virus il
vole pas il s'envole pas se déplace pas
tout seul c'est nous qui faisons
déplacer et cette compréhension de la du
passage d'un individu à un autre est
très présente très très présent et ce
qui est assez facilement quand on prend
l'exemple du vietnam alors qu'ils sont à
plus de presque deux mois maintenant
sans aucun nouveau cas ils viennent
encore de décréter qu'il fallait encore
renforcer les mesures de surveillance de
l'épidémie à doc a pas de cas il n'y a
pas de cas depuis cinq ans depuis deux
mois à la base et rocades il rend sur
cinq ans les mesures avec toutes ces
pédagogique où chacun essaie d'auteur
qu'est ce que vous répondez à johnatan
fois qu'il vous dit mais en fait il n'y
a pas de pays à imiter cette c'est trop
je suis absolument d'accord grâce à ces
beaucoup trop tôt on verra avec le recul
je suis absolument d'accord que
l'immunité collective en fait un truc et
une forme d'immunité elle n'est pas
encore collective on est à 15 20 % chez
nous et encore on n'est pas sûr on sait
qu'il faudra au moins dépasser les 50%
par une efficacité pour commencer à
vraiment freiner la propagation on est
certains n'y a pas des minimes objectif
du tout donc une forme de fragilité
d'exposition à ça si on ne trouve pas de
vivre deux vaccins ils sont très
fragiles
alors j'aimerais maintenant qu'on puisse
partir à tel aviv est-ce qu'on résiste
c'est possible parce que on en a parlé
israël c'est un pays qui comme nos arts
confiné totalement son territoire
bonsoir jean charles banoun et merci
d'être avec nous c'est un plaisir de
pouvoir dialoguer depuis tel-aviv en
direct avec nous alors expliquez nous ce
qui se passe chez vous je rappelle que
vous êtes l'un des visages de la chaîne
n24 news
expliquez-nous vous êtes en plein
déconfinement progressif c'est ça
extrêmement progressif exactement dire
que le gouvernement israélien se réunit
quasiment tous les jours et rendez vous
compte il a fallu une semaine de
réunions de discussion pour se mettre
d'accord sur la simple réouverture des
écoles primaires jusqu'aux ses amants
ces terres qui a une grande crainte ici
de ce qui s'est passé de des leçons
qu'on a tiré de ce qui s'est passé lors
du premier des confinement c'est qu'on
s'est aperçu que les écoles qui ont été
recouvertes quasiment au premier au tout
début parce que les parents voulaient
retourner travailler n'en pouvez plus
aussi peut-être d'avoir les enfants à la
maison
eh bien on a renvoyé tous les enfants à
l'école dès le mois de juin et c'est de
là les experts le disent aujourd'hui
avec certitude c'est de là que le virus
serpro page et à vitesse grand v dans le
pays alors qu'ils avaient été
extrêmement contenu lors de la première
vague donc aujourd'hui on réfléchit à
tout pour l'instant on autorise les gens
à retourner à la plage dans les parcs et
les jardins mais par exemple les
restaurants les cafés les centres
commerciaux tout cela est fermée les
lieux évidemment de culture de sport
tout est fermé mais il a fallu quand
même prendre une décision là et pour
l'instant on a décidé ben voilà on
rouvre les écoles primaires on laisse
les enfants allaient à l'école à partir
de ce dimanche là donc jusqu'au cm ans
mais ça va être extrêmement encadré il y
aura des capsules dans les classes et on
va voir ce qui se passe suivent dans les
classes donc c'est un déconfinement
perlé progressif est très prudent
comment le second confinement jeudi
secondes mais peut-être qu'un troisième
a été vécu par la population très mal
comme partout c'est à dire qu'il ya eu
énormément de manifestations de
profession qui sont détresse on peut
l'imaginer il ya des commerçants qui
n'ont occasion plus travailler depuis
six mois maintenant des énormément de
magasins qui sont alloués à vendre quand
on se promène dans tel aviv qui est le
poumon économique du pays
donc c'est un vrai problème il ya
énormément de d'angoise on le voit il ya
beaucoup de gens qui consultent des
psychologues et c'est une situation qui
inquiète beaucoup aussi parce qu'ils ont
perdu leur travail qui sont pas sûrs de
le retrouver
donc il ya un vrai malaise avec des
cours le confinement mais comme partout
mais en même temps les gens étaient
obligés d'accepter parce qu'il ya eu un
taux de mortalité extrêmement fort ici
qui a choqué beaucoup la population
il ya une dernière un dernier élément
avant de vous laisser repartir dans
quelques jours israël au 1er novembre va
tester un premier vaccin innovants c'est
bien ça il va être testée en fait il va
y avoir des wii pour la première fois
des volontaires des personnes qui ont
été recrutées c'est l'armé à supervise
tout ça parce que c'est le laboratoire
biologique de qui dépend de l'armée donc
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement secret
mais en même temps dont des éléments ont
été rendus publics parce qu'apparemment
ce vaccin a donné de très bons résultats
sur des animaux là on va le tester sur
des volontaires et des milliers de
personnes qui se sont portées candidates
pour tester ce vaccin et on verra
peut-être que l'an prochain pas avant
l'été à ont dit les responsables de
l'armée eh bien peut-être que ce vaccin
sera opérationnel merci infiniment jean
charles banoun merci d'avoir été en
direct depuis tel-aviv avec nous bon
courage pour la suite de ce
déconfinement progressif johnatan près
d'un vaccin en israël tester comprends
pas c'est pas le premier
c'est pas les premiers patients sains ça
c'est pas le premier individu sain qui
sont en train de tester un vaccin mais
ça veut dire effectivement les choses
avançaient ce qu'on peut en espérer un
pour nous aussi
quoiqu elle aussi à quelle échéance aux
différentes il ya déjà actuellement
plusieurs personnes des dessins qui se
font tester avec le vaccin les études
animales études précliniques on a eu
beaucoup sur plusieurs vaccins il ya
plusieurs vaccins de cette phase 2 qui
sont en cours alors on espère avec les
voilà qui se croient au père en était
trop et et qui seront disponibles au
plus vite possible
simplement quand vous entendez quand
vous entendez ce journaliste en nrl
expliqué qu ils ont d confiné très très
progressivement et que d'ailleurs les
écoles sont restées fermées
contrairement à nous pour danser ce
reconfirme ans qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire comme commentaire je peux
comprendre ce vraiment cette politique
puisque israël à l'instar des pays qu'on
a évoqué tout à l'heure contre le bien
ses frontières donc en effet c'est une
c'est vraiment une politique qui peut
valoir le coup de dire on va
complètement éteindre l'incendié mais
complètement et on va vraiment galère
attention à tout ce qui rentre ça peut
marcher
d'accord mais c'est vrai qu'on se pose
la crue la même question pourquoi pas
pour nous pourquoi pas au fond esther
duflo la prix nobel d'économie disait au
fond programme on ou un confinement à
une date précise dur mais au moins on
sera on sera prévenus
les commerçants pourront s'organiser
pour sauver noël c'est pas une solution
pour et d'indre l'instant ce sont vos
noël je crois qu'il va falloir prendre
un petit peu de recul avec ça c'est trop
près à mon avis pour qu'on puisse parler
de sauver noël on va voir à noël
différent moi je parle d'un homme de
combat mais pas un sauver noël
je crois que ça illustre surtout le fait
que perth
la solution bien la personne ne l'a on
tâtonne tous partout dans le monde on
tâtonne mais on peut tirer des leçons
quand même pour tirer deux leçons c'est
vraiment vraiment trop tôt pour vous
rendez compte que c'est extrêmement
difficile à accepter pour la population
ce que vous croyez vous que le brut
nerveux comment comment faire tenir un
pays quand on vous dit pratiquement un
an après l'épidémie
c'est trop tôt c'est trop tôt pour ne
pas se mettre dans un endroit d'erreur à
nouveau oui mais il faut le faire
accepter ses patientes je crois que là
l'humanité se retrouve face à un échec
collectif c'est à dire que la modernité
c'est l'idée qu'on va pouvoir vaincre
toutes les limites et combattre toutes
les toutes les maladies souvenez vous
qu'il ya cinq ans par le transhumanisme
on devait découvrir le gène de
l'immortalité
on nous annonçait que l'être humain les
850 ans au moins et qu'on allait craquer
le l'adn du vieillissement et là on en
meurt tous pour un un coronavirus donc
là ne sait notre impuissance qui est qui
je crois que c'est ça qui nous qui nous
déprime tous nous sommes impuissants
face à une maladie qui paraît bénigne
qui en fait est terrible et incurable et
le seul mot obscène de la modernité
le temps vous êtes agent à prendre la
peste nous a pas fallu un nom oui donc
dans l'histoire on espère qu'on a fait
quelques progrès pour être voilà peu
plus rapide cette fois ci quand même
sans rebondir sur ce qui a été dit sur
eux confie non nous de façon très très
dur pour ensuite pouvoir tenter de vivre
est-ce que fin ça impliquerait également
de ne plus bouger parce que si vous
combinez de façon dure ça signifie que
les personnes à un endroit donné
effectivement ne sont plus qu'à
contacter nous plus ok donc ça marche et
ça signifie qu'il faut rester à cet
endroit là donc ça signifie qu'en fait
votre vie vous l'a compris mais en
restant effectivement vous pouvez
ressortir mais s'est passé au mois de
mars mais reste chez nous avec la règle
du kilomètre donc donc en optant pour ce
que vous proposez un exemple pourquoi je
compose rien à part pose des questions
en fait votre question était pourquoi
est ce qu on opte pas pour un
confinement dur mais ça ne résoudrait
rien parce que si on doit pouvoir un
confinement dur ça signifie qu'après on
ne bouge pas et voilà et puis ma
deuxième remarque c on parle beaucoup de
ces régimes autoritaires
dix ans ils ont réussi à contrôler en
fait
l'expansion ce virus mais ça ces mesures
ont également entraîné une grande
pauvreté une énorme pauvreté sur c est
en fait la manière pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle n'explose pas cette pauvreté
c'est parce que justement c'est un
régime autoritaire et que les gens sont
sont réprimées en fait ils sont
contrôlés alors que la clause sociale
france et ce n'est alors pas le cadeau
n'atteindrait qu'on termine ce débat par
la situation à l'hôpital à la pitié par
exemple puisque vous y travaillez vous
êtes urgentiste ça monte j'imagine on
parle d'un seuil de 60% déjà à temps aux
patients qu'aux vide en réanimation
oui facilement facilement 60% et puis la
moyenne nationale montre une annonce
était poussé à paris c'est plus et 80
coups alors je sais pas trop quel
pourcentage mais finalement le taux de
ré de kovy dans l'animation on n'est pas
tellement informatif ce qu'il faut voir
c'est vraiment le total parce que on
oublie il ya quand même les autres
malades et donc ce qui est vraiment
parlant c'est de se dire que tout tout
ce qu'on peut déprogrammé est
déprogrammée c'est ça qui est terrible
tout ce qu'on a pu ouvrir comme l'y a
été ouvert et tout ce qu'on peut
déprogrammé a été déprogrammée nos corps
sont quand on se dit bon ben ça y
compris des opérations du coeur et
traitement des cancers donc alors on
essaye de ne pas déprogrammer certaines
choses qui vont avoir beaucoup d'effet
sur le pronostic comme typiquement tout
ce qui est des gnostiques de cancer ou
traitement du cancer mais on va être
limitée et un très vite donc là tout est
des programmations c'est ça qui est
terrible et c'est pour ça qu'on
confident fait et toutes les autres
conséquences dernière c'est à dire que
confiné et se disent si on ne confie
n'est pas justement ça qui est
intéressant de la réflexion il faut la
porter si on ne confie n'est pas un
modèle suédois
on aurait une explosion bien plus
conséquent du nombre de cas à l'hôpital
là on est certain on ne soigne plus
personne d'autre elle était conseillère
noir gascon les projections sont parfois
un peu voilent âge il faut enfin dès
lors des quatre cent mille bon c'est
vraiment la fourchette très très haute
mais c'est pas 20001 oui et puis surtout
c'est pas tant le nombre de morts que le
virus aurait tué c'est les gens qui
normalement ne seraient pas morts et
qu'on n'aurait pas pu soigner ça qui est
très important si tout le monde arrive
d'un coup à la fin j'ai même pas de quoi
donner de l'oxygène à un malade on peut
pas pour vous très clairement c'est un
soulagement cette mesure de rang
confinement bien sûr pour les pour les
séries spitalier et tous les profits
coup de frein brutal c'était
indispensable agement et encore il peut
être vu comme même s'ils ont tant mieux
on le comprend comme ça un peu light
limites qu'il est un peu light pas trop
parce que c'est tout à fait normal y'a
pas que il faut pas voir que non plus
par le prisme de l'hôpital et de la
santé va par l'économie également de
balance voilà donc est-ce que ça va
marcher
on croise les doigts pour que il ya
vraiment un impact sur les
hospitalisations et en gardant un peu la
vie économique en limitant la casse au
milieu de mon essai pascal bruckner vous
aurez le mot de la fin
voilà c'est bah c'est pas facile en fait
à entendre tout ce que vous avez dit au
fond on ne peut pas tirer de bilan
on ne fait rien cette incertitude qui
demeure et puis la troisième vague n'est
pas forcément exclu
comment on fait pour vivre comme ça
longtemps je crois que madame a dit la
vie compris mais oui la vie se resserre
autour de quelques fonctions biologiques
on reste chez soi au minimum
donc c'est une sorte d'horreur qui
radotent ya quelque chose là on est en
quelque sorte condamné à la banalité
l'existence biologique avec l'idée que
si on se retrouve on risque on risque
notre vie et celle des autres et c'est
je pense est une épreuve pas simplement
sanitaire mais métaphysique pour le
programme contemporain et nous sommes
nous avons été levée dans l'impatience
d'obtenir tout ce que nous voulons tout
de suite
et là il doit vouloir attendre très
longtemps et pour attendre tenir il y a
les livres on va en parler du vôtre à
présent pascal bodmer une forme de
revanche du vieux mâles blancs j'ose
l'expression que vous assumez être tout
de suite
[Musique]
alors on m'a parlé de votre livre dans
quelques instants mais évidemment je
voulais vous vous interrogez sur sur
l'actualité d'abord l'attaqué au couteau
dans la basilique notre-dame de nice a
mis évidemment le pays dans un nouvel et
froid c'est un peu la même question au
fond comment tenir comment tenir quand
on nous attaque à nouveau sur nos
valeurs sur ce qui fonde le pacte
républicain
ben là c'est pas la même chose est
requis il ya une guerre contre le
l'occident depuis depuis le 11 septembre
2001 alors certains l'ont nié pendant
longtemps mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui
cette guerre est évidente et la france
est à l'avant garde du combat puisque
c'est le pays qui a inventé la laïcité
qui a le plus grand nombre de citoyens
français musulmans sur son sol mais vous
pensez qu'on était assez fort il ya
beaucoup de responsables politiques qui
disent dans ce climat on est à la limite
de la guerre civile on craint des
attaques des représailles sur des
mouillères il ya un risque de guerre
civile mme enfin le pouvoir doit être à
la fois impitoyable avec les les
délinquants les terroristes djihadistes
et en même temps empêcher d on n'est pas
aux états unis ici on n'a pas le culte
de larmes à feu donc empêcher que des
individus privés fois justice attaques
des femmes voilées attaques des mosquées
car ce serait le pire cas de figure
donc on est vraiment sur un fil entre
deux disciplines c'est une guerre qui en
moins d'un mois une guerre culturelle
c'est une guerre militaire par une
guerre à bas bruit sur le territoire
français mais derrière il ya évidemment
le grand le grand grand sultan terreau
icr douanes qui a soutenu des sons le
sait qui a livré des armes qui envoient
des dix à dix à la fois en libye et en
os karabakh
donc c'est une guerre qui n'est pas qui
ne sort pas de n'importe où donc il faut
du sang-froid de la détermination mais
il me semble que la france n'est
peut-être pas si mal armé que cela pour
affronter les sombres temps qui arrive
alors vous avez entendu
évidemment les mode emmanuel macron sur
les caricatures lors de l'hommage très
bel hommage à la sorbonne au professeur
samuel pâtit nous continuerons
professeurs nous montrerons les
caricatures et les dessins
quoique ce front se feront d'unité de
solidarité sur la liberté d'expression
en soutien à charlie hebdo commence un
peu à se fissurer on l'a vu avec les
propos de mohamed sifaoui mohammed
moussaoui du cfcm qui explique qu'il
fallait renoncer à certains droits pour
que la fraternité s'exprime dans le pays
s'est certes corrigé que vous faire
entendre le ministre de l'économie bruno
le maire et puis ouvrage hissé juste
après moi je n'aime pas ces caricatures
mais je les défends je défends ce qu'ils
ont fait
je défends ceux qui les diffusent au nom
de quelque chose qui est plus important
pour moi que ces caricatures qui est la
liberté voilà la liberté plus importante
au fond d'eux que les caricatures qu'on
peut ne pas aimer elle symbolise ce
droit d'expression
ce matin le père jurdant de la basilique
de nice a dit moi je ne suis pas charlie
et j'en suis je suis en colère contre ce
discours qui sous couvert de défendre la
laïcité et la liberté d'expression
salissent les religions et finissent au
bout du compte par excité des fous est
ce que le oui mais revient en force dans
notre pays oui revient en force et plus
que dans notre pays c'est aux états unis
que l' attaque contre la france est la
plus violente en fait je vous disais le
washington post et le new york times il
pourrait être main dans la main avec
avec les mots d'ordre des rohan où deux
d'al azhar au caire
et si la presse anglo saxonne naissance
il a joué là dessus je trouve au dessous
de tout mais bien entendu les gens
commencent petit à petit à céder du
terrain
on n'est pas obligé d'aimer les
caricatures là bruno le maire a raison
mais il faut des ans défendre le
principe tout simplement au nom de la
liberté moi je suis chargé depuis le
début même si je le lis peuvent c'est
une question de principe on ne doit pas
transiger là dessus on a le droit de
critiquer le christianisme le judaïsme
le bouddhisme le confucianisme et il y
aurait une religion qui ferait exception
et on n'est pas trop celle en france
mais oui mais la france or ce combat
face à la scène internationale on à
l'euro
derrière nous alors il va falloir
maintenant que mâcon convainquent merkel
les pays bas la belgique la trouvaient
trop timide la chancelière sur ces
sujets elle est paniqué parce qu'elle a
deux millions de turcs 2 ou 3 millions
de turcs sur son territoire et que et
que air douanes la tient par samson
immigration de turcs sur le sol allemand
qui d'ailleurs se sont plus sûrs que
calment de très souvent donc le la
france est seul mais j'ai l'impression
qu'on a un peu à la veille de la
bataille de valmy
si on prend des références historiques
mais on est seul mais c'est un beau
combat c'est un combat juste un combat
sur lequel nous devons avoir aucune
hésitation
alors qu'il ya entre nous des divisions
des dissensions c'est tout à fait normal
mais sa part aux barbades interdit au
fond que la réaction la plus importante
doit venir de cette communauté
oui parce que la première victime des
attentats islamistes voilà si pourquoi
la france est-elle hays par les
extrémistes de l'islam frères musulmans
al quaida d'âge parce qu'elle offre aux
musulmans de france et aux musulmans du
monde entier ce que jacques berque
appelé à un islam des lumières c'est à
dire qu'elle leur offre la possibilité
de croire dans leur religion sans
afficher les signes extérieurs en toute
discrétion et sans être des croyants
assidus c'est exactement ce qui se passe
pour le judaïsme c'est ce qui se passe
pour le protestantisme catholicisme
on peut être un chrétien du dimanche et
on peut on peut aller que dans les
grandes fêtes religieuses et au fond ce
ne pas s'inquiéter de savoir si dieu
nous allons pardonner et saul bellow
disait en 1983 dans le new york times en
france dieu prend des vacances pour ça
qu'il adore les jolies formes et voilà
ils adorent venir à paris parce qu'au
moins à paris on ne le dit pas avec des
prières des invocations et je crois que
c'est ça qui fait très peur aux
fondamentalismes ici les musulmans
français qui sont faites très heureux
chez nous prenez goût à cette
désinvolture vis-à-vis de la foi alors
on en vient votre livre un coupable
presque parfait la construction du bouc
émissaire blanc vous êtes très en colère
franchement dans ce livre non non c'est
pas de la colère c'est pas quand même
j'ai pris un
centre cette idéologie venu de la gauche
américaine vous êtes quand même vous
dites les vieux mâles blancs occidentaux
hétérosexuels sont devenus aux yeux de
7,7 pense hélas cette génération là le
lead l'hallali d'humanité non mais
l'origine des malheurs du monde
ce point là ça fait longtemps que je
travaille dans ce champ puisque dans un
sanglot de l'homme blanc j'avais déjà
commencé à déblayer cette idéologie et
c'est pas simplement les vieux mâle
blanc c'est aussi les femmes la femme
blanche est maudite au même titre que
l'homme blanc en kwh apprécié alors en
quoi va cesser si des contrôles chez les
néo féminisme et les antiracistes et je
mets beaucoup de limay anti raciste
parce que pour moi sont des racistes
nouvelle manière et celle et des
coloniaux selon lequel l'homme blanc
c'est à dire le monde occidental est
responsable de tout ce qui va mal sur
terre qui n'a cessé d'imprimer tous les
peuples et qu'aujourd'hui ils restent
dominants et que donc il faut l'attaquer
dans sa racine qui est à l' on aurait pu
penser que c'était l'ailé le pouvoir
économique ou politique non désormais et
c'est là où je pense qu'il ya une chute
du progressisme c'est la couleur de peau
dire le simple fait d'avoir un épiderme
blanc plutôt qu un épiderme foncé fait
de vous un essentialisme le coupable
mais vous vous comprenez qu'on vous dit
comme ça juste en passant les anti
racistes sont des racistes ce ne soit
pas si évident alors un certain anti
racisme est pour moi une forme de
racisme new look qui est protégé en
quelque sorte par son par son label pur
sans étiquette et donc vix qui lui
permet d'attaquer un groupe précis et
c'est ça la fonction du bouc émissaire
un bouc émissaire c'est quelqu'un qui
sait une cible on a un groupe qui permet
de focaliser sur lui toute la tuta
méchanceté août et toutes les tensions
d'une communauté si on nous dit comme le
comme l'expliquent par exemple françoise
vergès où beaucoup d'autres que l'homme
blanc condense en lui toute la cruauté
du monde et que même quand il fait des
efforts pour ne pas être raciste il
l'est c'est une idéologie quidam et mais
vous savez que c'est compliqué à faire
passer cette idée là l'homme blanc à
lehman est aujourd'hui on se figer dans
les positions de pouvoir vous le savez
bien
statistiques le montrent le monde
économique dans le monde politique
n'attendez honda des manettes ou vous
avez les bannettes c'est à dire c'est
pas vous vous l'homme blanc mais quand
on regarde des instances dirigeantes
quand on regarde le cac 40
quand on regarde la gestion du coc vide
regardez le conseil de défense la photo
du conseil de défense est quasiment que
des hommes
est-ce que ça va là d'accord l'homme en
tant que masculin l'homme masculin je ne
suis pas sûre l'homme blanc hétérosexuel
alors la veille raison il ya des progrès
à faire moi je pense que la dynamique de
l'égalité enclenchée par le féminisme
est inéluctable et que de toute façon
c'est vrai qu'il ya un combat à mener
sur le pouvoir politique et sur le
pouvoir économique
il ya déjà des femmes qui sont dans des
positions très fortes que soit ma la
ronde 1 par l'ona merkel ursula von
ihnen la directrice du fmi
la féminisation des professions est en
marche
justice médecine et tout ça alors il ya
énormément de progrès à faire je suis
d'accord mais ça c'est mais de là à nous
expliquer que l'homme et l'ennemi de
l'humanité ce que font beaucoup donné
aux féministes l'homme blanc et et
l'homme blanc toujours plus que les
autres je trouve que c'est pas ça le
combat d'émancipation d'émancipation
consiste à briser les chaînes pour
réconcilier les personnes vous voudrez
victimes et est pas vous même ah non moi
j'ai non non non moi ça m'est témoin on
peut m'insulter on m'insulte pas en plus
au fur et à mesure que je vieillis mais
je le prends comme un hommage
alors tous les hommes seraient coupables
mais certains ne seraient plus que
d'autres c'est ce que vous expliquez
dans votre livre vous a préparé un petit
sujet qui va vous intéresser
puisqu'au fond vous fustigez cette
idéologie j'en parlais tout à l'heure
qui porte un nom aux états unis la can
seule culture cette culture de
l'effacement qui va au delà de la
culture de l'excusé lé 10 à réviser
l'histoire à l'aune de ces victimes
autoproclamées explications avec hélène
bonduelle les défenseurs adama traoré
décédé lors d'une intervention policière
musclée qui reprennent le slogan black
live matters littéralement la vie des
noirs comptes né aux états unis après la
mort de georges floyd le buste de
colbert tagué en france comme un écho au
statut de personnage historique des
boulonnais aux états unis
ou encore le hashtag nous tous qui
devient balances ton port la france sans
par guy lapointe salle culture anglo
saxonne
ce phénomène qui tend à vouloir effacer
une opinion qui dérange ou humilier
publiquement une personne
en fait c'est une offensive collective
qui se fait en général par
l'intermédiaire des réseaux sociaux mais
pas seulement et qui vise à s'attaquer à
une personne à sa réputation à son
statut avec pour but d'une certaine
façon de lui tenir aux etats unis une
culture militante identitaire s'est
développée ces dernières années
notamment face à une droite désinhibé ce
phénomène certains se l'approprient en
france pour un petit peu le même type de
militantisme donc c'est ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui les néo féministe donc
extrêmement radical est partisan d'une
censure qui n'est pas la censure d'état
mais qui à la censure des réseaux
sociaux en fait on a également les
militants lgbt donc qui lutte contre
l'homophobie
on a les militants antiracistes mais au
delà de l'influencé des réseaux sociaux
pourquoi la france s'empare tel de cette
console culture même si on nous sommes
un pays universaliste universalisme la
france s est un idéal ça veut dire qu'il
n'est pas toujours forcément réalisé
dans la réalité ce qui fait qu'un
certain nombre de personnes qui peuvent
avoir des ce2 porte des appartenances
communautaires diverses peuvent avoir
l'impression d'être discriminées avec
parfois réellement discriminés et à ce
moment-là il estime que la république
est coupable et elle utilise la même
stratégie que celles qui sont utilisées
par des communautés similaire aux états
unis alors qu'il s'agit de pays
complètement différent voilà qu'est ce
que vous répondez au fond cette porosité
entre la cancel culture aux états unis
et la france est-ce que c'est pas aussi
le signe que notre modèle universaliste
et en échec surtout le signe que la
gauche française et 1 et vendetta
d'effondrement complet que les loyers la
chute du mur la social-démocratie est
aux abois et donc toute une partie de la
gauche et l'extrême gauche sont tentés
de reprendre le modèle de la race de
genre de l'identité qui nous vient des
états unis et qui à mon sens n'est pas
du tout adaptés à la situation française
voilà que nous nous sommes mis au
printemps
endosser les crimes des américains et
même avion à ministre de l'intérieur qui
voulait qu on s'agenouille pour le
meurtre de jean reuilles de laurier
jamais fait jamais mais au nom de quoi
et la comparaison adama traoré genou
gêne c'est le genou à terre où c'est la
solidarité avec ce combat mais pourquoi
est ce qu'on a dans pourquoi est-ce
qu'on endosserait les crimes on a déjà
nos propres crimes mapa endosse donc
celle excuse celle excuses mais pas la
condamnation et nous ne sommes pas
américains insistent là-dessus nous
avons eu notre travail on vous dit
nous ne sommes pas américain on voit que
le rôle de l'université est centrale
dans l'importation à la fois de cette
culture là en france et aussi dans la
manière dont elle elle se met en oeuvre
elles émergent
et pourtant ce sont nos philosophes qui
oui qui les ont invités vous nourrir aux
états unis alors on n'a pas une petite
responsabilité là dedans oui il ya une
opérations d'import export mais je pense
que le l'idéologie north america c'est
la route ce cours théoriques d'une
gauche aux abois et d'une gauche dont on
se rend compte aujourd'hui avec les
attentats dont vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure
qu'elle a une certaine responsabilité
idéologique dans l'éclosion de cet islam
radical et on parlait d'antiracisme je
pense que le concept d'islamophobie est
un antiracisme criminel parce que c'est
lui qui a conduit à l'élimination des
douze charlie a libéré hier cher et à la
mort on a beaucoup déjà parlé de ce
terme d'islamophobie journée vous
ramener au féminisme au néo féminisme
tout n'est pas d'acheter dans le mot
mythe où il a fait plus de bien que de
mal
il a fait du bien alors là il faudra
plus de bien que de mal il a sans doute
fait plus de bien que de mal je ne sais
pas il faudrait faire un bilan
historique
est-ce que vous avez la dent dure aussi
non j'ai pas le droit non non je suis
beaucoup moins sévères que les femmes
les féministes antimite ou sont d'une
dureté incroyable mais simplement si
vous voulez moi je respecte l'état de
droit et je pense qu'on ne peut pas
jeter en pâture dans l'espace public le
nom d'un homme sous prétexte qu'on a un
différend contre lui et bien qu'il doit
être lynché et qui me faisait plus
apparaître dans dans l'espace public et
on a ce mouvement de libération de la
parole sur les agressions sexuelles
subies par les femmes
évidemment il allait avoir des outrances
et des radicalités évidemment une forme
de révolution aussi des mentalités est
ce qu'il faut pas
pour changer la société casser un peu d
eux c'est la question alors puisque vous
utilisez la formule des oeufs cassés qui
est une vieille formule d'aidé utilisé à
l'époque par les notamment par l'urss je
pense qu'on cassera beaucoup de on fera
aucune omelette
si le cil si le mouvement de libération
de la parole et si la lutte contre le
viol et agression sexuelle ne me pousse
pas les canons de l'état de droit
eh bien il finira en simple dénonciation
calomnieuse sur les réseaux et les
réseaux fusille à bout portant donc ces
six là où est le problème
et regardez philippe caubère regarde
ibrahim maalouf regarder ce chef
japonais qui s'est suicidée récemment
parce qu'on l'accusé d'agression
sexuelle
à tort le féminisme ne peut pas sauter
sous prétexte de justice immédiate par
dessus des lois de la république s'est
dit en tout cas c'est passionnant on
pourrait en discuter encore davantage un
coupable presque parfait la construction
du bouc émissaire blanc c'est aux
éditions comme toujours avec vos livres
grasset vous restez avec nous on va
retrouver à présent la chronique de
thomas des prêts la france sera confiné
l'assemblée nationale aussi n'est-ce pas
thomas les règles vont changer
oui exactement mariam ce matin à se
réunissaient exceptionnellement pour un
vendredi la conférence des présidents
c'est elle qui organise le bon
fonctionnement de l'assemblée
je raconte ce qui s'est dit alors
pendant que les français à se re
confinement assemblée nationale adaptée
bien sûr son protocole sanitaire
la décision a été prise ce matin en
conférence des présidents
il a été décidé de maintenir à 50% la
jauge des députés présents 50% des
députés en commission en hémicycle mais
aussi dans l'enceinte du palais-bourbon
il a été décidé de mettre fin aux
réunions en présentiel lorsqu'il n'y a
pas de vote au bout c'est à dire pas de
débat d'amendements pas de vote d'une
loi tout se fera désormais en
visioconférence et puis il a également
été décidé que le télétravail serait la
norme pour les collaborateurs
seul un collaborateur par députés
présents pourra se rendre ici sur son
lieu de travail alors pourquoi la
conférence des présidents a pris de
telles décisions
on est allé poser à la question à un des
vice-présidents de l'assemblée nationale
bonjour monsieur le président
vous êtes vice-président de l'assemblée
nationale c'est vous qui en séance et
quand vous présidez elle devait
appliquer ces nouvelles règles il y a un
devoir d'exemplarité du député alors que
la france est à nouveau confiné depuis
ce matin oui je crois tous les chefs
d'entreprise se démène pour essayer de
trouver les meilleures solutions c'est
ce qu'ils font depuis le début du virus
et je crois qu'on a effectivement un
devoir d'exemplarité avec l'exigence de
continuité on peut pas se permettre de
dire tiens ben arfa démocratie pendant
trois mois
c'est pas possible toutes les lois
toutes les décisions qui sont prises
elles dépendent de lois qui sont votées
au parlement
donc on a cette exigence de résultats
dans notre action et on a cette
obligation d'exemplarité comme vous le
dites tout à fait alors si bien sûr tout
le monde entend respecter à ces
nouvelles règles elles troublent tout de
même certains parlementaires pour demain
parce que les groupes puissent se réunir
un visioconférence comme présidente vous
moi je pense que le présentiel permet de
mieux échanger c'est très compliqué en
définitive de prendre des décisions dès
très réactif sur des textes de lois en
visioconférence
on doit exemplaires on doit éviter bon
respecter tous les protocoles mais il
faut que le débat ait lieu dans ces
assemblées s'il n'a pas lieu dans cette
assemblée il aura lieu à l'heure donc
c'est ailleurs donc c'est cette
difficulté qu'il faut surpasser moi je
suis pour cent pour cent de télétravail
pour les collaborateurs
donc c'est ce que j'ai dit en conférence
des présidents il ya une souplesse qui a
été accordé mais dans mon groupe
les collaborateurs sont passés à 100% de
télétravail dès hier soir
voilà même et ces nouvelles règles elles
peuvent encore évoluer elles seront
réévaluées toutes les semaines
en conférence des présidents merci merci
thomas ils sont tous là ils sont en
pleine forme c'est l'heure du bloc notes
avec tous nos chroniqueurs tout de suite
[Musique]
bonsoir françois durpaire on sent rien
vous allez nous faire vivre cette
campagne américaine comme tous les jours
on est à cinq jours de l'élection
isabelle lasserre bonsoir pour un
nouveau rendez vous on est ravis de vous
accueillir vous êtes au rédactrice en
chef adjointe au service international
du figaro et camille saféris je vous
rassure il a un seul sou va même pas
partie de ceux qui ont un regard
suffisamment à temps pour supporter de
l'euro gatineau on commence avec 7
avec cette campagne qui s'achève qu'avez
vous retenu 24 dernières heures intenses
et le lieu le lieu surtout la floride
parce que la floride c'est la mère des
batailles qui gagne la floride gagne les
états unis c'est un peu le slogan de
l'année 2020 aux états unis on va voir
quelques images ans pendant que je
parents vont pouvoir les images du
dernier meeting de donald trump et là on
voit alors compter le nombre de masques
ou plutôt compter ceux qui n'ont pas le
mal là c'est pas le protocole sanitaire
de l'assemblée nationale donc imaginer
que ces images et vous quelques heures
c'est le dernier meeting de la trappe à
tampa pas de masque et pourtant
généralement mais les masses derrière
pour montrer karnas là il y en a pas
mais il ya beaucoup de monde les gens
viennent
la bonne nouvelle c'est sa2 d'un train
de regarder il ya une bonne nouvelle
pour lui
on voit les images c'est le retour de on
voit les images nos alliés font
maintenant leur part au niveau mondial
notre économie a explosé et le chômage a
diminué
notre armée est plus forte que jamais
très bonne nouvelle pour donald trump il
a eu une épouse la first lady et elle
est sortie de son silence
beaucoup se guérir du coc u19
je dis ça parce que c'était
officiellement la maison blanche disait
ça c'est un atout pour dia en tout cas
oui de montrer qu'il ya quand même un
couple à la maison blanche il ya une
famille et donc ça c'est important
la vraie bonne nouvelle c'est le pib le
pib + 33 % lors du dernier trimestre il
en a beaucoup parlé de n'attrapez je
vais vous montrer des images parce que
ça se passait aussi en floride de joe
biden vous allez voir la différence
alors vous voyez joe biden il y avait
quand même un peu moins de monde donc là
un protocole sanitaire beaucoup plus
fort il enlève son me lève le masque
il enlève son masque et l'envoyer ya
personne quasiment on avait vu aussi les
images de barack obama qui tout en fait
venir du monde
le du fait du protocole sanitaire et
bien il ya très très peu
là c'est bon c'est bon alors deux
hypothèses la première c est ce que
c'est le protocole sanitaire qui limite
les gens pour aller voir joe biden et
les démocrates
ou est-ce que c'est simplement bas qui
n'intéresse personne
alors une petite réponse quand même en
images parce que le deuxième état où ça
va voter c'est en pennsylvanie un autre
hymne tête et regarder ces images il ya
quand même des millions d'américains qui
sont en train de voter des démocrates
et là on est dans la file pour aller
voter et voyez on a envie de voter 75
millions d'américains sont en train de
voter et notamment c'est un week-end
c'est ça qui va faire la différence 9
ans peut-être la mobilisation la
mobilisation des jeunes elle est intense
pour vous dire déjà les floridiens
il ya déjà quasiment 8 millions de
floridiens qu'ont voté hier plus de la
moitié des floridiens inscrits sur les
listes électorales et rien n'est joué et
rejoué malgré les sondages qui montrent
une tendance non parce que les sondages
peuvent se tromper
je veux pas être plus royaliste que le
roi c'est la chef de campagne de joe
biden qui a dit que rien n'était joué
que les sondages pouvait se tromper
elle vous a passionné de bout en bout
cette campagne non pas parce qu'elles
bouclent parce qu'en plus cela une
partie de ma famille est américaine donc
vie là bas
évidemment en tant que français je
préférais by donne il serait plus
aimable avec nous mais la politique
étrangère et serait la même globalement
l'europe doit maintenant prendre en
charge le fardeau sa défense mais
évidemment serait plus sympathique même
si bayonne envoi n'est pas aussi tonique
que l'incroyable trump qui sort
résultat vous fait rêver on dirait
sinon mais c'est hallucinant je ne sais
pas ce qu'il lui en donner mais ferait
appliquer ce traitement à tous les
malades deauville a pas eu d'itt roxy
chloroquine isabelle lasserre c'est
votre tour ravis de vous accueillir je
disais on va parler de politique
internationale avec vous deux le
vendredi désormais vous vouliez revenir
sur les outrances d'erdogan mais plutôt
sur le rôle et même la survie de l'otan
qui est en jeu oui mais rien me rappelez
vous c'était il ya un an emmanuel macron
avait donné une interview à
l'hebdomadaire britannique the economist
dans laquelle il avait affirmé que
l'otan était en état de mort cérébrale
il visait pas emmanuel macron uniquement
l'attitude méprisante de donald trump
vis-à-vis d'une organisation qu'il
considère obsolète il pointait du doigt
aussi les dérives de la turquie le seul
membre musulman de l'alliance qui
d'ailleurs a gardé avec beaucoup de
sérieux
son flanc sud est pendant très longtemps
mais qui depuis l'arrivée d'ardoyne au
pouvoir multiplie les les attaques
contre contre ses alliés achète du
matériel militaire vous savez les femmes
es400 un pays la russie qui veut la mort
de l'otan au nord-ouest de la turquie
on en reste de la turquie par pardon
elle attaque les kurdes du pays y dès
qu'ils étaient des alliés de la
coalition anti dahesh menée par les
états unis et vis-à-vis des alliés
européens
elle fait elle exerce un chantage
migratoire permanent menaçant d'ouvrir
les vannes et de déverser sur les routes
des centaines de milliers de réfugiés
alors à l'époque on se souvient très
bien les propos d'emmanuel m'apprend
elle est très très mal reçue oui parce
que quoi d'ailleurs
parce que la turquie comme les états
unis d'ailleurs est un sujet absolument
tabou à l'otan au sein de l'alliance il
ya une règle tacite
on ne critique jamais les alliés
d'ailleurs quand une frégate française
au mois de juillet
dernier a été prise à partie par un
bateau turc dans la méditerranée
orientale les alliés se sont efforcés de
d'étouffer la sphère de la deûle à 10000
ont repris très vite leurs politique de
l'autruche et ils ont à nouveau mis la
tête dans le sable d'un seul coup
pourtant sur le fond
emmanuel macron avait avait raison même
si la forme peut être mise en misant
mise en cause mais sur tous les fronts
le président sûr que multiplie les
attaques contre ses alliés ils violent
les espaces maritimes de la grèce et de
chypre
il intervient militairement en libye où
il en train de sa décidé de s'attribuer
le contrôle d'une deuxième route
migratoire
enfin il dépasse les bornes emmanuel
macron kill kill qui couvrent d' insulte
il appelle le monde arabo-musulman à
boycotter les alors il faudrait il
alimente le climat de sacrés dit
complètement l'idée qu'il ya un problème
erdogan dans l'otan il ya françois
hollande cette semaine d'ailleurs qui a
remis en cause la présence de la turquie
dans l'otan il a remis en cause la
présence de la turquie dans l'otan à
france inter
le problème c'est que il n'ya les
statuts de l'otan ne prévoit pas de
mesures qui puissent soit certes à
retirer soit exclure un membre de l'otan
par contre aujourd'hui il est sûr qu'on
peut légitimement se poser une question
c'est avec le le fragilisé par le
retrait américain miné par l'attitude de
la turquie
est-ce que l'alliance atlantique plus
sur peut survivre si jamais trempé réélu
pardon cobast vaste question où on n'a
pas beaucoup de temps pouvait réagir
très rapidement vous avez parlé d' air
dogan déjà je pense que la france est un
allié dans l'otan c'est la grèce mais
que la france doit soutenir tous les
ennemis de la turquie à savoir d'abord
et en premier lieu les arméniens du
haut-karabakh acquis nous devrions
livrer des armes ou là
carrément on devrait donc sortir de
notre position neutre donc la france
intervienne parce que c'est un génocide
qui menace s'est dit on va suivre de
près ce sujet mais pour l'instant la
france n'est pas majoritaire pour
bousculer erdogan de l'otan on termine
avec vous allez me détendre un petit peu
avec qui avez-vous pris
r cette semaine avec hervé berville
alors rg berville c'est un député en
marche des côtes d'armor il a 30 ans il
fait partie de la jeune garde de cette
mandature il est ce qu'on appelle un
breton pur beurre mais c'est un breton
d'adoption car il est née au rwanda
c'est un orphelin tutsi qui a été adopté
par une famille de pluduno j'espère que
je prononce bien
alors évidemment on a parlé fest noz et
puis surtout on a parlé crêpes cas jadis
ils ont dans le manger très souvent en
famille regardons après-midi bons
souvenirs ma grand-mère faisait aussi
des excellentes crêpes avec la vie la
particulière car elle avait une poêle
qui faisait des comme des petites
alvéoles en fait sur les crèmes et c'est
un peu sa signature c'est la seule tu
avais ce ce type de petites alvéoles
soirée crêpes les bretons auront de quoi
je parle
alors pendant son enfance en bretagne
hervé berville il a aussi appris à jouer
d'un instrument lequel a votre avis pas
du biniou pas de l'ain celtique pas de
la bombarde en fait pas du tout
l'instrument auquel vous pensez
j'ai fait de l'accordéon et vous juillet
quoi du breton demande que toutes les
archives et horner et très peu rigoler
comme lui parce que c'est vrai l'âge et
les partitions qui viennent en tête
giscard jouer de l'accordéon c'est vrai
il jouait de l'accordéon il y en avait
très tard vous êtes dans une famille
bretonne vous apprenez l'accordéon
asseoir français par excellence et puis
vous devenez députés à l'assemblée
nationale
c'est joli jeu je sais pas si ce joli
mais c'est c'est une histoire parmi des
milliers d'autres histoires français le
fait d'avoir les deux mains qui jouent
des choses différentes mais en même
temps il ya le lay à l'est c'est un peu
comme député c'est le local
le national l'international tout est lié
en fait et si vous ratez à un des trois
tout cela musique n'est plus très
éloigné
hervé berville il a une silhouette de
basketteur mais en fait c'est au foot
qu'il joue car il est milieu offensif
dans l'équipe de l'assemblée qui est
composé uniquement de dépit
les franges de l'assemblée
surreprésentés au jour et eric coquerel
avec adrien taquet qui est maintenant
nice donc ça permet de une à deux fois
par an de se retrouver d'avoir un moment
exactement il est c'est une équipe
vraiment parlementaire c'est-à-dire que
l'on peut avoir des on peut avoir
françois ruffin qui est à droite et
c'est exactement ça il est milieu droit
voilà ça c'est drôle il ya des mauvais
esprits
alors franchement il n'y a aucun mauvais
esprit mais pour la première fois depuis
la création de cette équipe
parlementaire
l'équipe a réussi à mettre plus 2 1 buts
donc on a mis deux buts à 2 tout premier
match qui n'était jamais arrivé
on a envahi le terrain pour manifester
notre joie est d'ailleurs lcp devrait
prendre l'engagement de retransmettre
ces matches de haut rang par les
prestiges bonaberi com je vous compte
sur vous pour en parler à la direction
je passerai le métal c'est parce que
d'être entendu merci beaucoup camille on
découvre les députés autrement les
français les découvre encore serré ses
députés en marche qui sont plus de plus
de 280 maintenant vous ne les connaissez
pas tous ces images y voit lui je le
connais c'est parce qu'il est d'origine
tutsi mais nous on n'y connaît pas puis
c'est vrai qu'il ya pas d'intérêt pour
les hommes politiques c'est terrible
c'est un métier affreux tout le monde
des critiques et personne ne se
passionne pour le re leurs réalisations
qui sont énormes
le niveau a diminué ou non le niveau a
pas diminué l'hostilité de la population
vis-à-vis de ses représentants et la
défiance qui a augmenté c'est très
dommage
merci à tous ses amis a très vite
isabelle françois vous restez on vous
retrouve dès mardi prochain parce que
non mais vous allez vous allez bosser
non mais c'est le week end mais on
compte sur vous merci à tous profitez
bien de ce week end et à mardi
[Musique]